madame la Présidente
en 2017 Monsieur Emmanuel Macron
président de la République
a déclaré
que lorsqu'un ministre était mis en
examen et lui paraissait qu'il devait
quitter le gouvernement d'ailleurs un
président
un précédent garde des Sceaux a été
amené à quitter le gouvernement je
constate par ailleurs que les avocats du
présent gardent des sceaux tiennent des
propos mettant lourdement en cause les
plus hautes autorités de la magistrature
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
monsieur le procureur général près la
Cour de cassation
dans ces conditions on peut se demander
comment le dit garde des sceaux peut
être garant de l'indépendance de la
justice enfin
je constate mes chers collègues
qu'il est tout à fait possible dans
l'état actuel des choses
que monsieur le garde des sceaux soit
conduit à contribuer à la désignation
du prochain procureur général près la
Cour de cassation qui sera ou qui serait
son accusateur
dans ces conditions j'en viens au rappel
au règlement monsieur carucci
j'ai l'honneur madame la Présidente
de vous demander au nom du groupe
socialiste
de vous demander de bien vouloir saisir
de ces questions monsieur le Président
du Sénat et de lui demander de demander
à madame la Première ministre de venir
devant le Sénat pour s'exprimer sur la
position du gouvernement sur les faits
que je viens de citer et sur les
conditions dans lesquelles danser dans
cette situation sera garantie
l'indépendance de la justice je vous
remercie merci
de votre rappel aux règlements et votre
demande sera bien entendu transmise à
monsieur le Président du Sénat un mot
sans aucune polémique l'attention de
Monsieur le Sénateur sueur pour lui dire
que mes avocats expriment ce qu'ils
estiment nécessaire à ma défense
deuxièmement
Madame Élisabeth Guigou pour qui j'ai le
plus profond respect
a été chargé d'un travail très important
sur la présomption d'innocence
l'impératif naturellement m'est interdit
lorsque je m'adresse à vous mais je vous
invite à le lire merci Monsieur bien
Desseaux
[Musique]